people are uh
extremely concerned these days with the
issue of
bullying um so let's let's talk about
that
let's talk about bullying and uh and and
the problems associated with it i think
if we're serious
about ridding the world of bullying
then we need to finally look at the
biggest bullies in america and those
would be
lgbt activists they are the biggest
bullies in america
um in in the latest act of viciousness
and vengefulness lgbt activists
shut down an adoption agency and this
isn't even the first adoption agency
they've gone after
and shut down this is just the latest in
a series because
you really know that your cause is right
and just and true
if you're going after adoption agencies
right that's a that's
a great indication that you're on the
right side of things when that's what
you're doing
um adoption agencies bakeries
yes these are the great villains that um
that the lgbt folks are taking down so
we should
they should applaud themselves but pat
yourselves on the back you're real
heroes
um anyway uh catholic charities
of buffalo is just another adoption
agency which was made to discontinue its
adoption services because
if you can believe it catholic charities
of buffalo
is catholic they're also
in buffalo so i don't know if but it's
the catholic part of that that was very
upsetting to
the lgbt mob um
because the organization would not send
children into
households with same-sex parents because
catholic charities abide by catholic
teaching catholic teaching is that
homosexual relationships are disordered
and
further children should have a mother
and a father that's not just catholic
teaching that is the belief of anyone
who any christian who takes the bible
seriously
so for that reason it was forced to
close down or to close down its adoption
facilities anyway
now here's the thing the organization's
original adoption policy
was not only morally correct but also
scientifically and logically correct
although that's kind of beside the point
the fact that they're right about it is
it almost doesn't
doesn't matter when we look at this
situation but i still think we should
stipulate that studies have
shown children fare better in
traditional mother father families
children in same-sex parented households
another study showed have
higher rates of depression suicide and
abuse but this is
this should not be a surprise to anyone
this is self-evident you shouldn't need
a study to tell you
you shouldn't need to research you
shouldn't need to read a book and say
well let me let me do some research to
find out
if um if kids should have a mother and
father i i need to do i need to do some
more
i need to do some more research into
that no any any rational person should
realize this
because every child in history has
had a mother and father every child who
has ever existed
or will ever exist or can ever exist
has had biologically a mother and father
no child can come into existence without
one
now this would seem very strongly to
indicate
that every child should have a mother
and father the fact that every child
does biologically would seem to suggest
that nature intends for every child to
have a mother and father
um in the same way
we can say that every person should have
two arms and we can arrive at that
conclusion
based on the fact that every person who
has ever existed
has had two arms unless something went
wrong
if somebody is born with only one arm or
no arms
then we know that there's been a
deformity or a mutation or a disease
we know something went wrong and we know
something went wrong because we know
that people
should have two arms and we know that
people should have two arms because
that's how people are that's
that's that's part of what it means
that's part of the human
physical identity is to have two arms um
if you don't have two arms then
something went wrong right um
same thing with with the fact that kids
have two parents
that's every every person in principle
that's
every person has two parents
biologically every person has two
parents
if a child is raised without their
parents or with only one parent
well then that means something went
wrong
there was there was a things didn't go
according to plan
somewhere along the line if a person
ends up without
both of their biological parents uh
if something is in principle
essential natural and necessary to the
human identity
then logically we must say that it is
how things ought to be
and ought to be maintained it is in
other words again
natural that is what's most natural
and if you're an adoption agency of
course you're going to look to put
kids into the most natural and ideal
circumstances possible
this this should be non-controversial
obviously if
you you've gotta you've got a child
needs to be adopted you're gonna look
for a mother and father for the child
but as i said the rightness of catholic
charities position here
is beside the point the real point is
that they have a constitutional right to
operate according to the teachings of
the church whose name is plastered
in huge letters on the building they
have every right to operate that way
they are the ones who have a right claim
they have a claim to rights here
the right to operate according to their
faith what what claim do the lgbt
activists have
the ones who are shutting down an
adoption agency on what basis
do they do they wage that campaign it
seems like there could only be
um two ways to justify it
the first one is they could claim and
they have claimed
that they're forcing um these adoption
agencies to let gays
adopt kids or else shut down because
they're worried about
the kids and what they say is well if
the kids aren't if gay couples aren't
able to adopt
then kids will be left unadopted but
that's
clearly ridiculous just because a
particular child
isn't adopted by homosexuals doesn't
mean that he won't be adopted by anyone
this is the false choice that you hear
the gay activists make all the time they
say uh
well what so you're saying it's better
for a child
to be left languishing in the adoption
agency than to be adopted by a gay
couple
that's not the choice there's a third
option the third option is that they're
adopted by a heterosexual couple
and there's a line 50 miles long of
heterosexual couples
waiting to adopt so by no means can you
argue that the lack of gay adoption
will necessitate that children will be
left abandoned in the system because
there are
many uh heterosexual families mother
father
natural families that are waiting to
adopt and that can adopt
and so if a child is not adopted by a
gay couple he is still could very likely
be adopted by a heterosexual couple
this this by the way is you hear the
same kind of argument when it comes to
adoption
um you hear the same kind of argument
from po
pro aborts where where they will say
well if you're so against abortion
then why then why aren't people lining
up around the block
to to adopt kids they are you
nincompoops that's exactly what they're
doing
there are tons and thousands of pro-life
families
that are desperately want to adopt and
have been wading through the system
trying to adopt and waiting to adopt
um so that argument is just not true
and besides which if you were really
concerned
about kids being you know about about
kids getting adopted
um then then clearly it makes no sense
to shut down adoption agencies
even if a small minority of children
have been left in the system because
they they weren't adopted by a gay
family
which isn't happening but even if it
were many many many more
will now be left in the system because
you're shutting down adoption agencies
so if this was really about the kids you
wouldn't be doing that
the lgbt activists if they really cared
about the kids which they
don't but if they did uh they would say
well look catholic charities i disagree
with their policy it's very mean it
hurts my feelings
uh however obviously they should be able
to stay open
and do what they do because they're
doing a wonderful thing and um they're
making sure that kids get adopted
and so let's leave them alone that's
that's how they if lgbt activists
if they gave a damn about kids um or
about anyone other than themselves
they would that's how they would
approach these situations
they would make their case they would
make their argument they'd make it
passionately
and then when they're told by the by the
other party concerned that listen
i hear your argument don't agree with it
these are my convictions
this is my organization this is how i'm
running it so i'm not going to do what
you want me to do
at that point if the other party if they
cared about kids
they would say okay all right
well then we'll you know we'll find an
adoption agency that will adopt
uh that we'll let gay couples adopt
so this isn't about children no it's
it's about
the homosexuals themselves as always
everything on the left it's always just
about
any time a leftist is arguing but all
their causes everything it's all about
them it's about their own advantage
their own priorities their own benefit
their own gain that's always what it's
about
now you notice when you go over to the
other side of the spectrum and i'll be
the last person to issue a
blanket defense of all conservatives or
to claim that they're all
you know virtuous and selfless and
everything like that because that's
certainly not the case but on the
conservative side of the spectrum
some of the movements traditionally
associated with conservatism
like the pro-life movement these are
selfless movements
like a pro-life woman does not
gain anything materially
from being pro-life she doesn't she
doesn't stand to gain anything from that
it's not it's not a selfish position
it's an inherently selfless position
because she's arguing on behalf of
children
and not only that but she doesn't it
means if she gets her way and abortion
is made illegal
and then she gets pregnant that option
won't be open to her either so that's a
sacrifice she's
willing to make but you notice on the
left there are no sacrifices
they never make any it's it's never
about anyone else never any sacrifice is
being made
it's always me me me me me this is what
i want
but what they will try to do and what
the lgbt activists here have also done
on top of saying oh we care about the
kids they don't um but they also well
it's about rights
this is a our this is a fight for rights
but what right was being violated if a
gay couple is told that they can't adopt
what right was violated the right to
adopt
that right doesn't exist children aren't
commodities
that you're entitled to possess you
don't have a right to a child in an
adoption agency that's a human being
it's not a thing you can own what kind
of person
what kind of person walks into an
adoption agency and says
i have a right to one of these one of
these are mine i have a right to them
what kind of what kind of arrogance is
that i mean it's disgusting
to to to i don't know how else to put it
they're not things they're people
and you don't have a right to them the
only children you have a right to if we
want to put it that way are your
own children so if you conceive
or give birth to a child you have a
right to that child
as in that is your child and no one has
a right to take him from you unless
um the law has to step in because you
are victimizing your child in some
horrible way
or if you do actually adopt a child you
know parents that do actually adopt
their
a child well that's their child in every
sense
of the word now that is their child and
no one has a right to take that child
from them
but the children who are not adopted or
adoption agencies and
you you know you're going and you walk
into an adoption agency
none of those children are yours yet so
you don't have a right to them
you have no legal claim over them
whatsoever
and besides which there are many rules
governing who can adopt
if we have a right to adopt then that
means that any old person should be able
to stroll into an orphanage
and adopt whatever kid they want with no
qualifications but that's not how it
works and that's not how it should work
talk to any
talk to any uh any any uh couple that's
been through the adoption process
they'll tell you
there are tons of hoops that you have to
you have to uh jump through probably too
many hoops but we i think we all agree
that there should be some
hoops i mean there should be some
qualifications
and so it's got nothing to do with right
it's got nothing to do with the kids
um it's just about being bullies and
this is just another in a long long line
of examples of the gay left
scorching the earth wrecking lives in an
effort to impose its ideology on
everyone
jack phillips is another of course
example you won a victory against them
in the supreme court but they haven't
relented they're still going after him
they're still trying to destroy his
livelihood and they'll continue the
assault
for another five years 10 years 20 years
until they get their way
and we're seeing this repeated across
the country with other bakers and
photographers and people in the wedding
industry
and so forth they're all being it's
being demanded of all of them that they
bow before the lgbt
altar or they go out of business those
are the choices they're being given
speaking of bowing before the altar just
this week brown university
pulled down a study which indicated that
teenagers become
trans to imitate their peers the reason
why this study was conducted is because
if you look around
and you see there's this massive uptick
in people identifying as trans which
doesn't make any sense if tr
if transgenderism is an actual natural
biological phenomenon
there's no reason why there should be
more of it now just because it's in the
news
so it really seems like you know kids
are are seeing how this gender fluidity
stuff
is in the news and it's in the media
it's in hollywood and so they're looking
and their friends are doing it too and
so they're looking at that and they're
saying well i guess i'm transgender also
um they're it's because of peer pressure
and because of um
uh you know because of
it's a trend basically well a study was
which
was conducted which lent some credence
to that view
but the lgbt mob reacted with outrage at
this study and they demanded that its
contents
be suppressed they simply will not allow
any discussion of the social and
biological facts related
to the trans thing
they will tolerate only a complete and
unthinking acceptance of their dogmas
and that's what makes them bullies
by the way keep this in mind keeping in
mind how the lgbt folks
suppressed a scientific study because
they didn't like the conclusion
not because they had any problem with
the methodology not because
they could scientifically disprove it
but they just didn't like the conclusion
so they
they insisted that it be suppressed
remember this the next time
the left demands that you produce a
study to prove some self-evident point
that you've made
well if you have trouble locating
studies like that this is why
because they won't tolerate studies that
contradict them they'll punish anyone
who conducts them
and they'll throw them out so and then
they demand that we produce studies
to prove our points after they've thrown
out all those studies
and they've you know burned them in the
bonfire and they threatened any
researchers
who might try to repeat the sin
the same thing happened with um with the
dsm the diagnostic
statistical manual of mental disorders
uh
lgbt activists insisted that
transgenderism
which up until a few years ago was
considered a mental disorder they
insisted that it be removed from the dsm
again not because there have been any
scientific breakthrough not because it
had
been proven that oh actually a a a man
with a penis can be a woman no that
never happened
they just didn't like it being in there
because it offended them
and it wasn't ideologically convenient
and so
for those ideological and political
reasons they demanded that it be removed
and they got their way as usual but now
they'll actually try to use that to
prove
their case so if you say transgenderism
is a mental disorder
which it is they'll say oh yeah well
it's not in the dsm
yeah it's not in the dsm because you had
it removed
you demanded they take it out you kicked
and screamed and stomped your feet
until it was taken out that's why it's
not in there as you well know
now i could cite a thousand other
examples but
there's no need the point is plain
enough lgbt activists are the worst
bullies in america by far it's not close
they believe that their goal is
manifestly good and so they can resort
to whatever means are necessary
to achieve it and that's that means
ruining lives tearing down businesses
leaving children without families
well as far as they're concerned that is
a price worth paying not even really a
price more like a perk because they
enjoy it
i mean they were celebrating when an
adoption agency was closed down they
were celebrating it they loved it
because they because that's how bullies
are they just want to get their way and
that's how that
they get their kicks that way
um and what is this good goal anyway
this
this good that they're working towards
well they'll say that they seek equality
but that can't be it because they
already have equality homosexuals have
all the same rights
as heterosexuals in fact they have
rights that heterosexuals don't have
for instance i can't um
if someone refuses to make me a cake i
can't go to the human rights commission
and complain about it
and have anything done they'll just
laugh me out of the room
but if you're homosexual you actually
have a right
supposedly in some states in many states
you have a right to cake that's a right
i don't have
um in fact the one and only inequality
that was left
between homosexuals and heterosexuals
the inequality was the rule prohibiting
active homosexuals from donating blood
due to the fact that homosexuals have a
much much much
much much higher probability of
contracting
hiv than a heterosexual non-drug user
the rates of hiv in the gay community
are much
much much higher than they are in the um
among heterosexuals and so for that
reason
logically if in the name of safety
um gay people were were not able to give
blood
but even that is now under attack and
those rules are being repealed
everywhere
the lgbt lobby will risk
giving hiv to hospital patients if it
means
they get their way they will shut down
adoption agencies
they will risk giving hiv they will they
will uh
tear down businesses ruin lives take
people's livelihoods from them that's
what they'll do
and has nothing to do with equality so
if equality isn't the aim then what is
the aim tolerance
they want tolerance well homosexuality
is not only tolerated but
celebrated there's not going to be any
parades marching down the street
celebrating my sexual proclivities no
that's that's only what homosexuals have
so they have much more than tolerance
they have in many quarters
something much closer to worship which
is what they demand
so what is the point it's not tolerance
not equality
well the point is just vengeance spite
imposing their will expressing their
hatred getting their way
power they are bullies
and that's all the gay rights fight in
america is anymore
because they have all the rights
and so now anytime someone says they're
fighting for gay rights that's not what
they're fighting for
they're fighting to impose themselves
now that's all it is
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening godspeed